i've been waiting for this to start so i
could personally thank you
for well that's a little bit too much
come on
actually it's not because i think you
helped a lot of
people in various creative
businesses and arts realize and
help us pave the way to just not be one
thing
it made it possible for people to take a
chance on us
because they looked at your brand and
thought oh i want a piece of that
and if that person can maybe bring that
and it was because of your billion
dollar
incredible financial success also i
think what you did
um which also was a very tone setting
thing for women in business was
make it authentic uh make it true to
yourself make it something that doesn't
seem like such a banana's departure like
what are you doing
um for people to take a step into
your world and literally walk in your
shoes
and so i thank you on behalf of all of
the people
who have been brand builders since you
launched yours
because you made it viable for us all to
do so because
yours was such a success so you really
are the original
like watch people like at the airport or
walking
down the street i mean we love street
style i was
dating a guy at the time and i would
look at everybody and
how they dressed their very best to be
at his concert and like what was their
outfit
and like i really that was like kind of
my mold like i looked at everybody what
they
dressed as their best and i was like i
you know that that type of stuff helps
the inspiration behind everything
i'm like you know that was that was like
at the beginning and like hmm i wonder
what concert that was
well well i updated some of a couple
musicians though
some under the radar that people don't
know about but we like to
come secrets i'm so curious
well that is definitely not being told i
will say
it's always fun your phone number i'll
call you and tell you
for sure and it's also just so fun when
you can get away with it
i don't know if you've had this
experience also there's something really
embarrassing about when you go on like
one date with a guy and all of a sudden
you're
inextricably linked and everybody thinks
that you've had this whole thing and
you're just like
i don't even know them i was i thought
about it
but now i'm like i'm linked to you i
always
felt like um
i mean yes i had my list and i checked
my list off as if i was a dude or
something but
i i did
i felt like any time it started to get a
little
bit serious like i was the person
to run from because every guy would be
listening to their publicist who would
be like
stay away stay away you'll never be a
respected actor you'll never be a
respected
musician if you're dating her but that
was you know
back then so at least that was the
excuses i heard
kind of random flow that i just gave you
i felt like we're like
two friends talking sorry listen
we've been through some bizarro
unorthodox
you know life romance
uh writing i i do find you know
i hope it's not okay i hope it's okay to
very inspirational for me as i was
on my uh way to writing open book and my
memoir
like um listening to your voice was
awesome it was soothing it was
entertaining um there's so much
about your memoir that i really just
admired and um yours was one of the
first that
like i studied before i
you know got into it but i mean i really
just opened all
of my journals from my past and it kind
of all
married itself into um
just a very interesting
take on my inner child and
in the release of the memoir and now
having
to like be i get to be partners with
amazon which is awesome and have all
these projects
in you know the work so it's it's fun to
release your narrative your side this
story your truth
and your honesty and just to show that
you do have flaws we're all trying to
work it out in this life you know we're
all just trying to
do it the best we can and to manifest
the great the greatness in ourselves i
have
so much respect because in some ways i
feel like mine was easier because
i was a kid and i didn't have
a family at stake and then when i got
divorced it was such a
tragedy for me personally that
i i really flailed
as a human being failure in general like
i feel like as uh
creative people and artists like were
such perfectionists
um and me even growing up like
in the church and as a preacher's
daughter um
you know i had like a standard of what
marriage was supposed to be
and um oh wow it really wasn't that
within the first week
so it was like
whoa okay so it's not like like that
fairy's hell
but i got married really young i
remember
and i mean you know did the religious
services also
you know give a blueprint for how you
would live
with inviting the world in and really
again let's just talk about you again as
a paving the way leader you did
a television show before there was such
a thing there was not even
almost reality tv it was a new genre
like the first is it the osborne's
in the real world and then nick and i
yeah yeah so like for our
marriage i mean it was definitely like
stressful we did have fun i mean
up until like the last like the end of
the last season did it get to be
just overwhelming because we were at a
place where
our communication was no longer
communication anymore like it was very
one-sided
on each side you know and for me
like i just because i have
you know a a pedestal to use my gifts on
it makes me no different than anybody
else like
i was even judged um in the church uh
growing up like singing um on stage like
i had to wear like blazers vests
turtlenecks because if i
just wore um a regular shirt like all
the rest of the girls i mean
when i would sing i would feel the holy
spirit and get chill bumps
and apparently people would lust and so
i had to cover it all up
so i've i've literally been judged for
my body like
since i was a kid i had that judge
in the church and then after the church
it was like
no be sexier but then it was like oh but
you always have to look that way if you
do it once
you have to remain that body forever and
that's
that is what you shouldn't be you know
like i mean turning in my weight to the
label it's not okay
you know but i you know i was reading
the story of your scale
and that you know when eric threw your
scale away
when you were weighing yourself with i
think it was birdie right
well yeah i mean i got yeah
i i was much heavier than my husband who
played in the nfl
so that pregnancy really did mean almost
5'4 260 was real heavy for me
i love that you took that scale and you
were like
throw it out i don't want to look at it
anymore like when i would go into the
doctor's office i would just stand on it
backwards i'm like just don't tell me
i mean even though i had to work really
hard to get the weight off like
i did it and i committed and i think if
you're disciplined
it can come off i mean you could still
eat
a dang cookie you know what i mean like
i hate diets
i know i do too